ja die meisten vorteile spieler haben
ihre mobile einladungs bereits vor
wochen erhalten und dann gibt es mich
heute dass ich habe es jetzt auch
spielen kampf steuerung ja die werde ich
brauchen so sieht das ganze auf dem
handy freunde hier kann ich springen
hier kann ich mich dunkel wenn ich bauen
will mache ich einen das ist ja mal das
ist ja mal komplett bescheuert also den
bau modus finde ich echt blöd gelöst
aber okay es ist auf dem handy also auf
dem handy haben dass ich nicht so gut
machen will kann ich mir noch eine hilfe
anzeigen lassen daher das wichtigste was
ich eigentlich brauche ist das hier eine
rakete dir den vorteil habe ich mir auch
geholt freunde
ich würde sagen wir befinden uns in
einer bis in dem bad die börsen so
übrigens dass ich hier so dumm sitze mit
hemd und allem aber es ist ostern und
ich dachte ich mache mich mal schick für
euch damit menschen nicht gesenkt
nämlich abstoßen da ich das noch nie so
richtig auf dem handy gespielt habt
springe ich jetzt einfach mal raus aber
ich glaube ich bin jetzt als mit einer
der letzten rausgesprungen
ich weiß wie bringt man handy gerade ich
will ehrlich gesagt gar nicht in die
stadt gehen oder so da vorne ist ja rio
das heißt da geh ich mal lieber nicht
hin sind hier überhaupt irgendwelche
anderen leute ich glaube nicht dass ich
gehen alleine dieses gebäude hier vorne
schöne auf dem dach landen
hier kann ich wie ok und da muss ich
dann so hofft hier ist keine kiste hallo
freunde ich schneide ich gerade das
video und ab jetzt hat vorteile einfach
kein tor mehr weil es irgendwie nicht
mehr funktioniert hat also hey lasst
leica so geht man den türen
hier ist eine pumpgun jetzt ein bisschen
munitionskiste ist er leider nicht
vorhanden
wir springen wir mal hier unter die
steuerung ist echt ein bisschen
umständlich aber wie bereits gesagt
freunde auf dem iphone kann man das
ganze auch irgendwie nicht so gut lösen
hier vorne haben eine falle ich meine
ich werde nichts reißen habe ich damit
sie trotzdem mal so ein paar sachen mit
sie gehen jetzt mal hier in den bau
modus klicken man hier auf die treppe
bauen wir hier mal hingehen wieder
zurück auf unsere waffe können jetzt ihr
hoch und sehen hier ist eine kiste das
heißt dann kann ich jetzt einfach
draufklicken und ich hasse die armbrust
auf das ding mit der armbrust und
vorteil ist finde ich einfach so die
nutzt man nicht um gegen welche gegner
oder so wirklich zu bedrohen oder zu
töten oder keine ahnung was sondern
einfach nur wenn man im team spielt
seine mitspieler abzufangen ich weiß
ehrlich gesagt auch nicht wie ich jetzt
hier irgendwie schieße oder wie ich
richtig anwesend mein gott er ist ein
typ darum ist einfach ein typ o mein
gott alter das kann doch nicht wahr sein
soll da erst mal nein ich will den baum
wo das ich will in den schuss modus
freunde alter das ist nicht wahr das
kann nicht wahr sein dies hat die
funktioniert das denn die stetig denn so
was ist das für eine steuerung ich habe
übrigens drei einladungs codes freunde
also wenn ihr noch wortlaut nicht auf
dem handy habt dann schreibt einfach in
die kommentare und dann kann ich euch
gleich zum einladung scott senden
ich liebe die lobby die grafik hätten
sie auf jeden fall ein bisschen besser
machen können auf dem handy also da
hinten das sieht ein bisschen kinder
mäßig aus der bus liegt hier noch sechs
sekunden das heißt ich geh jetzt eben
raus und wir fliegen da du scheiße das
display glaube ich hier fliegen mal da
hinten ans ende der welt ich weiß
ehrlich gesagt nicht genau was dass sie
hinten ist oder wie das heißt ich glaube
das ist der schrottplatz aber ich die
letzten male allerdings immer sehr
erfolgreich er hier vorne haben wir
schon direkt im waffen zwar ist es eine
falle sehr gut luca wasserkiste haben
wir gerade hier in dingen zu bekommen
eine pumpgun springe ich manche vorne
haben wir nämlich ein ja ich denke ich
mit dem ziel fiel hier vorne was machen
kann ich weiß noch gar nicht wie das
funktioniert also da oben habe ich jetzt
90 4 angebracht dass
jetzt kann ich wahr wird höre hier schon
wieder eine kiste das heißt wir bauen
jetzt hier einfach mal was hingegen hier
hoch geht wieder raus aus dem bau modus
soll uns unsere spitzhacke kloppen hier
vorne die wand sei ein bisschen weg
wohnen meine damen und herren wir sehen
schon hinter der band verbirgt sich eine
kiste und da haben wir dann schlurft
rang der ist so lecker der schönen baum
modus eine treppe hinbauen freunde hier
oben haben nämlich noch eine kiste
schauen mal das was hier drin ist da
haben wir richtige scheiß sachen ich bin
auf jeden fall gar nicht weit außerhalb
von der zone noch ne kiste meine damen
und herren wir schon was hier drin ist
wir haben eine weg geknallt bombe die
heißt nämlich genauso locker gibt es
andere leute die auch hierbei direkt bei
kälte draußen bringen und auch da alles
rasieren und so freunde ich hab's doch
kein einziges mal auf dem handy gespielt
des während ich bin halt auch einfach
scheiße wie wer bin ich denn außerhalb
ich bin ja weiter außerhalb kann man
eigentlich nicht sein drei wochen später
ja hier geht gerade die sonne auf in vor
neid wir vorne waren spieler freunde ich
war mir gar nicht echte freunde
das ist unfair
das ist unfair das hat geruckelt und da
hat geblendet an der stelle mich dass
heute das allerdings auch beenden meine
damen und herren leider hat mir epic
games erst vor einigen tagen diesen code
zugeschickt und leider war ich die
letzte woche in miami und in madrid
wegen einer sache die ich nicht sagen
darf aber jetzt bin ich wieder hier und
deswegen ist es das aufnehmen wenn euch
das ganze allerdings trotzdem gefallen
hat dann will ich mich sehr über einen
daumen hoch freuen habt ihr tipps für
mobile ich denke ich wenn es ihn nicht
noch einmal spielen weil es mich ein
bisschen abgefuckt hat ich bin gerade
noch hier bei meiner familie in
bielefeld für ein zwei tage wegen ostern
dies ist die weihnachtsstimmung und weil
weihnachten luca allerdings bin ich von
dienstag bis samstag an der nordsee das
heißt dort werden mega keine videos
kommen ich habe alles durchgeplant wir
werden da nicht dumme sachen machen
sonst würde ich an jetzt da können jetzt
eigentlich auch nur noch sagen dass
wasser
vom video das was jetzt hier vom video
hier können jetzt jemanden kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen job
ausschenken jetzt findet ihr zwei andere
videos und managen abonnent seid könnt
ihr auf die glocke klicken dann
willkommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]